well greetings welcome and thank you for
being here especially if this is your
first time with us Adventist or
otherwise so a couple of months ago my
friend Mike curn joined me for Open Mic
number five where we open the floor to
any Seventh Day Adventist in the world
to change our minds regarding the great
controversy worldview and storyline
being biblical this time he's with me
again but we are focusing on the 7th
Adventist Church's interpretation of
Revelation 14 6-12
so the formal challenge of the
night can any Seventh Adventist prove to
us the uh Revelation 146 through2
teaches what the SDA Church
claims that it does can any Seventh
Adventist prove to us that Revelation 14
6-2 teaches what the SDA Church
claims that it does for those unaware
this is one of the SDA Church's favorite
six verses in the Bible and it's uh
somewhere that they try and trojan horse
in a truckload of doctrinal claims these
are then hitched to the phrase the
Everlasting gospel found in verse six
which the SDA church asserts is
referring to their unique message of
Salvation which is informed by their
worldview that we looked at in the last
Open Mic only they possess this message
allegedly and no one else has it so the
floor will be open again to any Seventh
Adventist in the world who wants to
prove to us that these texts are indeed
teaching what the SDA Church claims
because as we are going to see believe
what they claim the text is saying is so
vital so important that a person's soul
hangs in the balance if they do not
accept it and we will see why this is
the case because before bringing any
Challengers on stage like always I will
give a brief overview to really make
sure the objections are made Crystal
Clear then the floor will be open to
seventh Adventists so if you are not a
Seventh Adventist please refrain from
joining um and by Seventh Day Adventist
I apparently have to say this because of
the last time um because of our friend
Ricky by Adventist we mean a sth
Adventist in the official sth Adventist
Church trademark that kind of Adventist
not whatever he was so the link to join
is pinned in the chat for those who
would like to step up but a couple
housekeeping things before diving into
it if you like what we're doing here
please consider partnering with us at
answering adventism tocom this ministry
is a viewer supported effort that is
only made possible by the generosity and
support of our YouTube members and
website Partners it is you who make this
possible and uh equip us to have
essentially have the impact that we are
having equipping as many Christians as
possible to reach as many seventh day
Adventists as possible with the true
Christ and his gospel so if you would
like to take part in that and see it
grow please consider joining us the link
to do so is in the description box down
below thank you so much for your
support secondly this Thursday the next
installment of for the record will go
live on this channel and it just so
happens to be with my guest tonight Mike
curn these uh for those that do not know
are unique interviews that are shot from
a documentary standpoint where I am
testing the SDA Church's theory about
why people leave their ranks we start
from childhood and work up through the
present day Mike has an incredible story
and so make sure to ring the
notification Bell so that you can be
notified when that premieres next week
but with that said brother thank you so
much for being here how you
doing I am doing amazing um man it is
good to be here there has been so much
going on and I have been so grateful for
all of the the content you've been
putting out all the stuff that you've
been doing all the hard work I don't
think a lot of people un well maybe they
do maybe they understand all of the
intentional hard work that you do but
thank you so much for being who you are
miles I appreciate that man I uh it's a
labor of love obviously um it's always
funny when we get people that say it's
about the money or I had a guy uh I
don't remember if it was yesterday or
this goes show it's like they think I
just sit around and and just sit on
YouTube all day it's like well no
there's other things that I that I do
but I got charged of being a
grifter I'm using I'm using adventism
for grift you're clearly making millions
doing this I know oh I know we were
gonna shoot this folks we were going to
record this from the Private Island the
the answering adventism Island that we
purchased um but I wasn't able to to pay
for the fuel for the private jet to fly
down and pick up Mike from Arkansas and
and all that sort of stuff so well
before bringing any Challengers up if
any decide to show up like last time I
want to give an overview for our
audience members who may be new to this
subject so they can get caught up to
speed so I'm going to read through some
sources for them and then the floor will
be open if no one shows up you and I
will chop it up until they do sound good
sounds like a plan man all right so
simply put the SDA Church claims that
Revelation 14 6-12 is God's final
warning message to the whole world
notice SDA Theologian John Pauline notes
this in his teaching series on
Revelation where he says quote the final
message of Earth's history is depicted
in the form of Three Angels this comes
very close to the heart for seventh day
Adventists in fact seventh Adventists
have often referred to their version of
the Gospel of Jesus Christ as the Three
Angels messages the final Eternal gospel
is given in the context of Endtime
events close quote now I appreciate Dr
Pauline's forthrightness here that
Adventist have their own version of The
Gospel it is not what Christians believe
teach and spread not even what the
apostles preached like we will see in a
moment but very clearly they claim that
Revelation 14 6-12 is ultimately talking
about a special end times gospel message
that only the SDA church has okay in
line with that assertion the angels are
allegedly representative of the SDA
Church which is taking this final
warning to the world as Ellen White said
in the January 25th 1910 10 issue of
signs of the times quote these Three
Angels represent the people who accept
the light of God's messages and go forth
as his agents to sound the warning
throughout the length and breadth of the
Earth close quote so that's one the
angels in these verses supposedly
represent a movement that was birthed in
the 19th century of North America that
is heralding an entirely unique end
times gospel message that is the final
message of God to the
world secondly regarding the phrase
Everlasting gospel notice what SDA
pioner James White husband to the
prophetess said about this in their
Church paper November 18 1862 quote
another scene and another chain of
prophetic events is introduced in these
verses we here have what is known as The
Three Angels messages of Revelation 14
the first Angel is called another Angel
because John had already seen one flying
in a similar manner chapter 8 Verse 18
He proclaims the gospel not a new one
but the Everlasting Gospel called in
Matthew 24:14 the Gospel of the Kingdom
but while it is the same gospel there
are particular features which constitute
the burden of the message Chief among
which as shown by verse seven is The
Nearness of the Kingdom this message
cannot therefore symbolize the preaching
of the Gospel by the apostles nor by the
reformers nor by any class of of people
except those who live when the end is
just at hand the Advent Proclamation
especially from 1840 to
1844 completely answers to this to the
prophecy and is the only great religious
movement which can be pointed to as its
fulfillment close quote so Revelation 14
6-12 isn't only referring to their
unique message that only they have which
has unique features not even preached by
the apostles such as the investigative
judgment
but it also is supposedly prophesying
about the millerite movement of 1840 to
44 so just like they insert the
millerite movement in the great
disappointment of 1844 into Revelation
10 9-10 we also see it inserted here
this understanding was allegedly
confirmed by God through Ellen White in
multiple writings here's just a sample
great controversy page 457 quote the
preaching of a definite time for the
Judgment in the giving of the first
message was ordered by God the
computation of the prophetic periods on
which the message was based placing the
close of the 2300 days in the Autumn of
1844 stands without
impeachment the repeated efforts to find
new dates for the beginning and close of
the prophetic periods and the unsound
reasoning necessary to sustain these
positions not only lead Minds away from
the present truth but throw contempt
upon all efforts to explain the
prophecies close quote so God was
allegedly behind the millerite movement
as well as all all the false date
setting of 1843 and 44 because it was
supposedly prophesied about in
Revelation so that's two Revelation 14:6
is supposedly talking about the
millerite movement of the 19th century
but getting even more specific on this
phrase Everlasting
gospel again from their Church paper
which is abundantly and sufficiently
clear
quote this movement with which we are
connected stands for certain great
fundamental truths the existence of God
the ins spiration of the Holy scriptures
salvation alone through the vicarious
sacrifice of the Lord Jesus repentance
regeneration and the gift of
righteousness by faith the work of the
Holy Spirit the immutability of God's
law The Binding claims of the Bible
Sabbath the Priestly Ministry of Christ
in the Heavenly Sanctuary the
investigative judgment now going on the
soon coming of Christ to take his
children home the doctrine of spiritual
gifts the manifestation of the gift of
Prophecy in the remnant Church Life only
in Christ Christian Temperance and other
lead ing important Bible doctrines these
great truths constitute the Everlasting
gospel message for this time to the
Seventh Adventist Church has been
committed this message close quote so
once again Revelation 14 6-2 is
allegedly a unique one-of-a-kind message
that only the Seventh Adventist Church
has been given to take to the world and
this Everlasting gospel more fully is
the entire 7th Day Adventist system of
theology in other words it is embracing
a great controversy Paradigm which is
what we looked at in the previous Open
Mic so that's three Everlasting gospel
in this text is allegedly referring to
the SDA Church's unique system of
theology which is entirely funneled
through their extra biblical Great
controversy worldview storyline whatever
you want to call it which includes that
the word judgment in Revelation 146 is
supposedly talking about the
investigative judgment
then in connection with the first Angel
we have what they assert about the other
two which is Downstream from and
connected to all of this Spirit of
Prophecy volume 4 Page 232
quote when the churches spurn the
counsil of God by rejecting the Advent
message speaking about millerism the
Lord rejected them the first Angel was
followed by a second proclaiming Babylon
is Fallen is Fallen that great City
because she made all nations drink of
the wine of the wrath of her fornication
Revelation 148 this message was
understood by Adventists to be an
announcement of the moral fall of the
churches in consequence of the rejection
of the first message the proclamation
Babylon has fallen was given in the
summer of 1844 and as the result about
50,000 withdrew from those churches
close
quote so when Christians of the 19th
century rejected the fanaticism of
millerism which was supposedly heralding
the first Angel's message God rejected
those churches and that's what the
second Angel's message is Alle allegedly
proclaiming in Revelation 14 this is a
vesage of Charles Fitch and millerism
that has carried over into present day
Adventist theology but that's four the
second Angel's message in Revelation 148
is supposedly a prophecy about needing
to get out of protestant Catholic
Orthodox Etc churches because God has
rejected them they are morally corrupt
and fallen and we need to come join the
remnant of the seventh Adventists who
are uh warning the world about
this then the third Angel they assert
this is talking about heralding the
warning against worshiping the beast in
its image or receiving the mark of the
beast which will be worshiping on
Sundays after the church and the state
unite and pass a Sunday worship mandate
which will be the image of the Beast
they then contrast those who receive the
mark with the Saints who keep the
Commandments of God in the faith of
Jesus AKA The Seventh Day Adventist once
this Sunday law is enforced they'll have
to take a stand against it and stand uh
instead of they'll have to stand for
Saturday essentially which will result
in them receiving not the mark of the
beast but the Seal of God which is
supposedly found in the fourth
Commandment and the seal uh of the law
being the uh the fourth Commandment in
the Ten Commandments as Ellen White was
also clear about in multiple places
multiple times repeatedly
quote I was shown that the third Angel
proclaiming The Commandments of God in
the faith of Jesus represents the people
who received this message and raised the
voice of warning to the world to keep
the Commandments of God and his law as
the apple of the eye and that in
response to this warning many would
embrace the Sabbath of the Lord close
quote
so that's five the third Angel's message
in Revelation 14 9-12 is supposedly a
warning about Sunday being demonic in
origin set up by Satan as a deception a
tradition of men and anyone that doesn't
come join the sdas and observe the
seventh day Sabbath They will receive
the mark of the beast because they will
obey the coming Sunday law versus the
sdas who will take a stand against such
and receive the Seal of God but wait
there's more
except I forgot to update the uh actual
quote itself which is hold on I can fix
that sorry folks I got a duplicate slide
in here but that's why it's nice to have
sources like this okay just one
second
okay all
right let's try this
again
whoops
okay let me full screen
it quote the health reform I was shown
is a part of the third Angel's message
and is just as closely connected with it
as are the arm and the hand with the
human body I saw that we as a people
must make an advance move in this great
work ministers and people must act in
concert God's people are not prepared
for the loud cry of the third Angel they
have a work to do for themselves which
they should not leave for God to do for
them he has left this work for them to
do it's an individual work one cannot do
it for
another
meaning apparently the SDA Health
message is also a part of what's going
on in Revelation 14
9-12 and that's being taken to the World
by them as well
okay so here is a summary of what is
question Revelation 14 6-2 allegedly a
saying overall it's it's allegedly about
a special end times gospel that only the
Adventist Church has the angels of
representative of the SDA Church the
first Angel's message is referring to
millerism and the investigative judgment
the Everlasting gospel and Revelation
146 is supposedly referring to the SDA
Church's unique message of Salvation
including the investigative of judgment
the second Angel's message is allegedly
about Protestants Roman Catholics Etc
who are apostate Babylon and they need
to leave their church and come join the
SDA Church the third Angel's message is
supposedly about a coming Sunday law
which will be the mark of the beast
whereas joining the SDA church and
observing the seventh day Sabbath as
they have defined it will result in
receiving the Seal of God and six
Revelation 14 9-12 is also supposedly
about the message of Health reform too
and I'd like to remind everyone like I
showed in the last Open Mic Ellen White
said the remnant church is supposed to
jump at the opportunity to do such and
defend these positions diffuse the light
that they have in every direction and
show sinners like us what we must do in
order to obtain salvation according to
this Everlasting gospel message okay so
the floor is open for any Adventist in
the world that wants to focus on any
particular aspect of this and show us
from the biblical text that this is
what's going on in Revelation 146
through 12 Mike what are your thoughts
on Revelation 14 uh according to them
I'm glad you had me off the screen when
you were reading those because I
couldn't stop shaking my head
I
oh yeah I know Bonkers just you know
three years before I have a quote here
you may have you probably seen this but
three years before she died Ellen White
explicitly said that the Three Angels
message like the third specifically the
third Angel's message is the most
important thing for avenus to take to
other people yeah she said it's the the
most important message ever given to the
world
yeah yeah all
right it's just crazy to me I I thought
Christ's death I thought that was
something that
was yeah it's just fascinating that uh
they'll they'll tell you we like Ted I
played all the time I'm Gonna Keep and
I've said this before I'm gonna keep
bringing this up I'm not going to let
this die until they stop saying this
because it drives me crazy we only
uphold the historical grammatical method
of Bible
interpretation yeah utilize that in
Revelation 14 and and tell us how you
can arrive at the the applications you
guys arrive at using the hgm let let's
hear it I'd love any advents in the
world if they could preferably a scholar
of some sort John Peckham or whoever
bring some person on here who can
explain to us utilizing the hgm how you
arrive at what they edce out of
Revelation 14 using that method I'd love
to because you'd have to conclude that
John when he was like having this Vision
was somehow seen this this millerite
movement like 2,000 years later to like
that's what was going on like that makes
no historic it makes no sense in the hgm
and not just that but the hgm to to
arrive at valid like NE app present day
application you have to establish what
was going on with the original audience
why was John writing to his soon to
persecuted audience about
millerism like how would that make any
sense and and Ellen White explicitly and
the Adventist Church believes this that
the first two angels messages have
already been
fulfilled well and not just that I
talked about this in one of the members
only streams uh well the last one the
last Q&A that we had um because somebody
was asking about this and she basically
tried to claim that like they had to be
rocla again so the first and second
Angels message went out but then they
had to be proclaimed again which is
where it totally switched to because
Miller wasn't wasn't proclaiming that it
was talking about the investigative
judgment and like you know these sorts
of things that came out of the
disappointment and so when that happened
then it became a spin job where it was
like oh actually no no no it has to be
rocla again and then it became about the
Sabbath and the state of the dead and
warning people about that which
millerites were not warning people about
that so yeah it just there's no way you
would arrive at that through historical
grammatical method of interpretation
because zation to the original audience
yeah people forget that John's like
again this is revelation it's
apocalyptic literature but John
specifically wrote to seven churches
like this had to have meaning to those
seven churches and this whole like
millerite movement stuff wouldn't have
meant anything it would have made it
would have been nonsense it would have
been it would have had no significance
to the audience that John was writing to
well and it's predicate too upon this
like I I still hear some Adventists that
will say this in the modern day because
this is what they were claiming in
millerism because whoever they were
exposed to in their small little sphere
of reality they broad brushed that out
to like the whole world whatever they
experienced in their small little
reality that was what the whole world
was and so because they came across
people that were like well we can't
actually know what Revelation is saying
there's this undertone of well we've
cracked the code we God showed us and we
do know what it's saying everyone else
believed it was a closed book until we
came along folks this is nonsense I have
with me right here um the oldest
Commentary on Revelation in existence
Andrew of cesaria Commentary on
Revelation is the oldest Commentary on
Revelation that we have actually I take
that back um we just don't have the full
thing I have Victor rus' commentary here
which is a an amalgamation no pun
intended of a number of commentators
from the 3 Century up to um the
venerable who was a medieval Theologian
in the so so you mean miles this this
idea that aist were like re like trying
to rocla something that had been lost
you mean that's not that that that's not
true no no no not at all people have
been talking about and and Revelation
has been getting expounded upon and
executed upon for I mean by the time the
millerites are around over a thousand
years I mean well over a thousand years
and so it's just silly it's not to say
that I don't necessarily agree with
every commentator there on everything
that they say but the point being is
that um the the reason you have your
standard positions on his like
methodological interpretation of
apocalyptic literature that you have
today is because of the groundwork of
individuals like that you amongst them
you have some who were futurist leaning
you have some that were uh prist leaning
you have some that were modified
idealist leaning like myself um then you
had some who were premillennial you had
some who were a millennial and you had
some that would be considered like
optimistic a millennial and so it's just
silly that they they tout this out as
though it's like we've cracked some
special code and the Book of Revelation
is All About Us
ironically Pro probably one of the one
of the best Scholars that has influenced
my I mean there's multiple ones that you
are I know have appreciation for Beal um
is one of them I know that you uh that
you um of course you've got all the hard
copies I've got it all in my digital
library but David is very good as well
but Dr Heiser Michael Heiser which is a
guy that really transformed my entire
perspective one of the things I really
value that he has said is um he he
basically says he he hates all end times
systems all eschatological systems
because every single system has a hole
in it somewhere because the whole the
whole purpose of apocalyptic literature
is that it's not supposed to be
understood until it's already been
fulfilled until it's already like done
yeah I've heard Adventists that will
they they will say yeah we agree we
agree and they'll try to use that as
support for why their interpretation is
actually correct because until it was
fulfilled in the 19 century no one
really knew whaty can we actually read
Point Dr heiser's getting at no can we
read Revelation 146 7 I mean like then I
saw another angel I know you're pulling
it up um I just find it interesting that
I think a lot of times avenus will
engage in Dialogue on this and they
haven't even actually read the text and
what it says and what it doesn't say um
take the
organizational yeah um I mean I
can I don't know what version you have
it in but uh
nesb okay and I saw another Angel flying
in mid heaven with an eternal gospel to
preach to those who live on the Earth
and to every tribe Nation tribe language
and people can I just pause for a second
just just pause for a second okay did
the millerite movement preach this
supposed
gospel to Every Nation tribe language
and people yeah do you know their
response to
that a horrible one it it ties back into
so folks for those that want a deep dive
on this go to our website and on the
left hand side quick click questions and
answers scroll down to uh Three Angels
messages and read the articles on the
first and second Angel's message because
I go into that in there it goes in back
into what I was telling you about this
reimagining and reinterpreting of uh the
first and second Angel Etc because
obviously they recognized that millerism
didn't go to the entire world but that's
what they claim is presently being done
through the present 7eventh day
Adventist Church and they'll tout look
how many countries we're in we're in 20
you know 213 countries what other group
is in that many countries we're going to
all tribes tongues peoples and Nations
and Jesus can't return until this
message go it's like no dude this is the
gospel that Jesus gave to the apostles
that that's what's being talked about
here is the gospel that Jesus gave to
the apostles going out to the entire
world that's what it's talking about not
some special present truth end times
gospel I do appreciate that John Pauline
the very first individual that you put
and it's so funny because you were
absolutely right when I was like doing
some rep work on this and I had found
the same exact quote without even
knowing you were going to put it up um
which by the way those of you that are
looking at this quote this actually is
in a this is in a what would be an
online digital theological like class
like this is what the the church teaches
this is this is what you from
reation yeah this is his Revelation this
would be a seminar Seminary level like
academic class and
you know new uh New Testament 386 in
their um sth AVST perspective on
Revelation so you can't disagree with
this I mean I guess you can but you you
wouldn't line up with aan perspective um
so it's it's very clear and I find it
ironic that second highlighted area in
fact sth day avist have often referred
to their
version their version
okay of the Gospel like this whole idea
like they've got a different kind a
false gospel some people say that or a
different gospel like at least John
Pauline has the nerve to actually State
the truth here it is absolutely a
different gospel and it is incorporated
into their framework of the Three Angels
messages yeah and I just want to remind
folks John Pauline has uh whether
knowingly or unknowingly just committed
the galatian heresy there um I mean full
stop Paul very plainly says folks
there's only one gospel there's not a
limited gospel and the fullness of the
gospel and all these sorts of things
I've shown before with Herbert Douglas
and all sorts of other Scholars where
they try and do sophistry and word games
on all this stuff to try and make it
well like we saw James White it's not a
new gospel but it has new components
that the apostles didn't preach yeah
it's a false gospel that's what it is
it's not what Jesus gave to the apostles
in Luke 24 and then sent them out
beginning in Jerusalem the proclamation
of the of of the the work and person of
Christ for the Forgiveness of your sins
now that's a limited Gospel According to
some of their Scholars they have the
fullness of the Gospel yeah Paul calls
the fullness of the goel apparently the
apostles died for a limited gospel yeah
they didn't even have the Everlasting
gospel supposedly the apostles didn't
have this fullness of the Gospel I'm
Amazed that you're so quickly deserting
him who called you by the grace of
Christ for a different gospel which is
not just another account but there are
some who are disturbing you and want to
distort the gospel of Christ but even if
we or an angel from heaven or three
angels from Heaven should preach to you
a gospel contrary to what we've preached
to you he is to be a cursed anathema
damned as we said before even now I'll
say it again he reemphasizes it if
anyone's preaching to you a gospel
contrary to what you received he's to be
a
cursed who who received Mike who
received the Galatians and who they
receive it
from Paul the apostles which he then
goes on to say in the next few
verses for am I now seeking the favor of
people or of God or am I striving to
please people if I were still trying to
PE essentially be a people pleaser I
wouldn't be a bond servant of Christ for
I would have you know brothers and
sisters that the gospel which was
preached by me is not of human invention
for I neither received it from man nor
was I taught it but I received it
through a revelation of Jesus Christ not
through a revelation of LG
white or any human for that matter I
mean Christ is obviously has has a human
name but he's clearly talking here about
it was not of some mere human origin
like like this is the other thing Ellen
White actually contradicts this we have
an article on this on our website too
she claims that Paul was taught the
gospel by the
apostles no no because when Paul gets to
Jerusalem and F and meets up with the
apostles the reason the apostles
legitimately know that he had a
revelation from Jesus Christ is because
he shares the gospel with them and they
knew we didn't teach this to you you had
to have gotten this from Jesus Christ
himself so she contradicts the
scriptures here as well again we have an
article on that for those that want to
check it out but the point being is
there is no version of The Gospel see
there's this undertone as well Mike and
I'm sure that you saw this when you were
in adventism there's this undertone of
like well Baptists have a gospel
Presbyterians have a gospel lutherans
have a gospel so we're just like
everyone else we have a gospel too and
then you kind of have to like find which
one is the right no no that that's not
at all what's what's going on the
problem is the looseness of language um
and I've started getting a lot more
precise on this um I'm going to be on a
friend's podcast in a couple weeks
talking about the Adventist gospel and
I'm going to be getting into this some
on there because when we talk about
false gospel if you only go that far or
that deep with an Adventist in my
experience you're going to do a lot of
talking past one another because they
don't really understand what it is that
you're what are you saying is false so
I've been having a lot of conversations
with SDA is trying to get more technical
with them and I've been seeing a lot
more success there's the objective
aspect of the Gospel which is the actual
message itself which is what's
summarized in the Apostles Creed I would
say the apostles and the ncing Creed who
is God and and what is this message and
you know God is Triune born of a virgin
suffered under pontious pilot lived a
perfectly sinless life died buried rose
again on the third day for our
justification and for the Forgiveness of
our sins Etc the actual message there is
then the subjective aspect of the Gospel
meaning how is one now benefited thereby
that good news how do you actually
receive the benefit of it you don't
receive benefit by just hearing it so
there's objectively the message and then
there's subjectively how are you then
benefited by that Catholics and
Protestants for example would disagree
on the subjective aspect of the Gospel
Orthodoxy Etc but we all agree for
example on the objectivity of the Gospel
the thing that's interesting about
seventh day adventism is they're off on
both the objectivity and subjectivity of
the Gospel they're not even correct on
just the message itself they Trojan
Horse and add all sorts of things to it
yeah I I have found um it's been a weird
experience I'm sure you experienced it
when you know early on when you left
adventism but for me a lot of the things
I was told that was like out there or
people believed out in the Christian
World outside the circles of
adventism I like actually isn't what
they believe like it's like a it's like
a weird buffer that Adventists like
project on you know the the congregation
to to like convince them everything's
fine here what we believe is normal what
they believe out there is awful this is
our present Truth by by the way the
three angels's message is also included
in the present truth concept yeah um so
I have just found like wow that's not
the case like Christians actually on
most things on most things Christians
are united on E even all the different
denominations on the core things of the
gospel and what Christianity is like
they are all United on it what separates
them is all these secondary things that
aren't tied to the actual you know the
actual gospel itself yeah but see the
problem is they can't differentiate
between secondary level doctrines
everything is seen as salvific
everything you have to have all 28 all
28 of them it's not even just that they
don't even have for example a uh a
fundamental belief on
sin you ever noticed
that they just assume their faulty
understanding of sin throughout the
beliefs wherever they mention there's
not even a fundamental belief on that
that's because of their belief on the
Ten Commandments they already know what
sin is it's just it's just yeah it's
well the thing that's interesting too is
like like you said is all this hubub I'm
working on a series currently that's
gonna uh we're going to do the first one
oh in two or three weeks I can't
remember exactly um where I'm going to
be going through it's going to be a
multi-part thing where I'm going to be
tackling this from a different angle
because I'm big on
um I like to try and Trace things back
to Origins like where did all of this
start like what was the what was the
first Domino that like started this sort
of thing so I'm kind of tracing that and
along that the way uh well the overall
thesis is tracking this this war the
Adventist Church's war on the Christian
church and so um that you're G to get
into Babylon obviously and where that
comes from and Charles Fitch and the
millerites and why Ellen White was
primed to be to be accepting of such an
idea due to her own experience with
methodism and these sorts of things and
there's just there's so many vestages
that are carried over from all of that
stuff and it really just all comes down
to in my opinion it comes down to this
sort of just angst and disdain that
Ellen White had for the Christian church
that still is is permeating their their
system today and then out of that as
well you get this idea of um we have it
all figured out we have the theological
God Particle God showed it to Ellen
White we were reward wed for our deep
Bible study you know all those
Protestants and Confused Babylonians out
there they don't really understand the
Bible in fact their preachers when
they're preaching Through the Bible are
actually deceived by Satan and the
people in the pews they're false
converts who aren't actually studying
the Bible for themselves they're just
taking what their deceived preacher is
telling them because Satan's using him
as a tool these sorts of things that she
said in spirit of Prophecy but uh all of
that to say it it's just laughable it's
like what are you talking about you're
you're not a presbyterian I'm a
presbyterian yet I guarantee you I
guarantee you you and I have more Unity
than the average 7thday Adventists if I
were to bring three seventh day
Adventists here and started asking them
stuff about what is considered core for
them versus what we are considering core
I could you're G to get 15 different
answers from three different people you
are going to get they're not going to be
able to explain the investigative
judgment to you they're not going to be
able to explain the seven-step sanctuary
typology they're not going to be able to
explain any of this stuff yet their
primary source documentation telling us
this stuff is fundamental to
understand so well and and I think
what's challenging I mean I I just had
some conversations just recently because
i' I've kicked off a series on um on on
the law on Sabbath and some of the
things that we've been dialoguing on but
um many times when when an AVST
responds it's oh s silly you Mike I mean
I this is just the simple reading of the
text I don't know why you're so confused
why are you trying to make it so
complicated and it's like it's like this
weird flipped like psycho I don't know I
don't want to say it's psycho but like
the way they understand scripture is in
such a bubble that has to and and it has
to conform to Ellen White even if even
if the the person doesn't actually
believe in that's what's that's what's
weird is I had another individual even
this evening say well like well I
studied scripture without Ellen White
and I came to my own conclusions
ironically everything lines up with
Ellen White even though I don't I don't
accept Ellen White like how does that
happen yeah because clearly you've been
influenced by a system and you don't
understand that this system filters all
this stuff through Ellen White's
commentary I don't care it's like I was
just at the former AVST conference last
week out in California and had some
great ation out there met a lot of great
people and this is one of the things
that we talked about is
like so many former Adventists are
asking what do you say to Adventist
because they there's so many that love
to say my pastor never even mentions
Ellen White I never even hear Ellen
White these sorts of things friend you
just don't understand how this works
Ellen White's name doesn't even have to
be mentioned I guarantee you I guarantee
you you have vestages of Ellen White's
theology in your thinking whether you
understand that or not whether you've
picked up any of her books or not
because I can start asking you questions
and you're going to give me answers that
are coming essentially from Ellen White
you've simply been given those by the
organization I get it I was there at one
point too Mike was there at one point
too I get it and what they mean by it's
based on the Bible is I have a proof
text that I can point to like Revelation
14 folks this whole chapter is about the
wicked being judged William Miller had
that part correct for all his other
craziness and errors and his method of
Bible interpretation his rules that he
came up with he was actually correct
that this is a chapter all about the
wicked then in this reimagining of the
the first and second Angels message that
oh it's actually warning about Sunday
keeping and the immortality of the soul
and it's letting people know about the
investigative judgment well the
investigative judgment is supposedly
only for professed
Believers all this stuff is them
supposedly giving a warning to
Christians who are a part of the wicked
world so that's why they they see no
problem with yeah this chapter's all
about the wicked you're part of the
wicked no I'm a
Christian this chapter is not about me
but see that mil no no you're not Miles
because you worship on Sunday you can't
be a Christian but at the same time they
they're Christians just like we are
you're my brother we're we're brothers
it's just I I have a new nickname for
this system mic and I call it
schizophrenic theology because that's
what it is it is just like every turn is
just con stantly something so this whole
chapter is clearly about the wicked it's
not about warning about but again you
have to have that underlying
presupposition of God has rejected all
of them we're the remnant we're special
we're the apple of God's eye the
depository of his law we're repairing
the breach of the law um we're we're
essentially you know warning against Pap
the papacy and the coming Sunday law and
church and state and and all these sorts
of things and so all those apostate
Protestants they're uh they're basically
no different than in the Wicked World
and so yeah this chapter can be about
them but no it's it's not it's it's
about the whole book of Revelation is
about the church essentially I would
argue is is essentially an overview of
all of Redemptive history from the
essentially the Ascension to um the this
the escaton the the entering into the
consummation of all things and it's
essentially the modern application for
us today is an encouragement that in all
ages whether you live in 2025 or 600 or
11 00 Christ has overcome the world he's
ruling and reigning all of his enemies
are going to be conquered and throughout
the the leading up to the escaton the
enemy is going to be Waring against the
Christian church and the kingdom of God
but it's not going to Prevail because
Christ has already overcome the world
that's the overarching theme so this
chapter is in complete accordance with
that and it's talking about the gospel
that Jesus gave to the apostles going
out to the whole world nothing about
young Earth creationism and Darwinism
and protest and Roman Catholics and
seventh day sabbatarianism I mean it's
crazy Mike they'll point to the word
well look it says worship Him who made
Heaven and Earth well go back to to
Genesis 2 now where it talks about the
Sabbath and God resting in creation and
young Earth creation if you don't all
because of like a single word that
they'll just latch on to so very clearly
it's talking about these things that's
that type
ofu but that
honors sorry I just hit the mute button
that honors um really the I don't mean
this to be too sarcastic but it honors
the way William Miller actually studied
I mean he he studied with a Bible in a
concordance and so he was all about you
know he's all about like finding a word
and then trying to latch that word onto
you know and I and I fundamentally think
that and I think this is true with all
humans I think we all are trying to do
things um right I I don't think that he
thought he was trying to be decep or
wrong I think he had good intent when he
repented so but Adventist actually
forget that he actually he actually
repented and went back like he didn't
stay in his like actually Ellen White
would have called him a condemned Satan
like tool of the devil because
he because he rejected his own meth
message and apparently that's that's
like not just that the Visions the
visions that come after all that she
says that the people that ended up
giving up that didn't continue going
along with the the new theories and that
sort of stuff they fell off the The Path
down into the wicked world that God had
rejected so that included Miller yeah
but yet here you go here's your
schizophrenia right because but yet she
basically says he was amazing like he
and he's gonna be in heaven doesn't she
say something about that he was an
American reformer yeah she talks about
his crown if I remember correctly that
he's gonna have a glorious you know
crown or whatever I got into at the
former AVST conference Mike I'll be
curious I want to hear your thoughts on
this um since we're
kind of on this subject what what did
you hear when you were in adventism
about the the special
Resurrection did you ever hear about the
special
Resurrection in reference to like those
that were resurrected with
Jesus well so you know that they
normatively speaking within Orthodox SDA
theology they teach about they teach two
Resurrection events there there's the
resurrection of the righteous at the
beginning and then at the second coming
yeah and then they'll go off to heaven
for a thousand years and Satan will be
alone because all the Wicked Will be
killed off by the brightness of his
coming Etc after the time of trouble and
then Satan will be bound on the earth
for A Thousand Years by himself and
they'll be up in heaven doing the second
phase now after the first phase of
judgment the investigative judment
judgment is finished they'll have the
millennial Reign judgment where they're
going to be looking over the books and
looking over what God's about to do in
the final third phase of execution of
that of of judgment um they're gonna be
able to look over and see why is Grandma
not here and and why you know the angels
apostatized and these sorts of things
and then after that the they'll be the
resurrection of the wicked where Satan's
going to have one final Harrah and then
they're going to be destroyed with fire
but
but if you go into the vision which I
see a lot of former Adventists that like
to explore upon this um if you go into
the the food for worms Vision where some
people that are here are going to be
alive when the second coming happens um
during that era of time there was a
teaching around the special resurrection
that those who were heralding the Three
Angels messages they were going to have
a special Resurrection for
them oh did you ever hear about that
when you were in adventism I don't think
I
ever where is that in the
Bible yeah um so how many how many
resurrections are we up to now three can
we have more like the ones that just
decide that after the after the after
they get burned they want to come back
can we just have another one can we like
make up some additional ones for well
again I I I haven't heard anything about
the special Resurrection
in modern times for for a man maybe
they're still I think they've kind of
tried to because this was tied to the
144,000 that the the modern scholarship
has eventually they just landed on
saying well we were never very specific
about
it we just said it was a group of people
who's gonna be alive at the second
coming oh except for all those years
where they were like completely changing
their theories
around so so I will say some of the
books um I have read on elleno and I
know this is so this this is the Big
Challenge I think for current Adventist
um I think it's difficult for Adventist
to pick up a book by a former Adventist
or by a not even an I mean even if like
Ronald numbers is where I'm going like
Ronald numbers his book while it's not
the easiest
read yeah it's a scholar what he does is
he puts her Vis like Ellen White's
Visions in the historical context of
when they were given and why they were
given to help to help an Adventist or a
former Adventist understand why she was
saying what she's saying and what you're
what I concluded what I really saw
through all that is I didn't
realize the I'm going to say this in a
way that I'm G to I didn't realize the
weapon that she wielded when she had
Visions because she really did wield
Authority
so things like you know things like
tithing people don't understand where
tithing comes from in the aen system I
mean that literally we a the avenus
system would not have their stewardship
Doctrine if it wasn't for Ellen White
and at first it was turned down by the
Pioneers they didn't want to do anything
but then you know Ellen White's husband
went and put this together and then she
had a vision after that that like
stamped it and like well they had to
inform because well they saw her as
authoritative when a vision was given so
Not only was it when when Visions were
given to her but then she would have
them on her own and she would cast
judgment on people I mean that's a lot
of the letters that she wrote a lot of
the manuscripts that a lot of a lot of
wish that they hadn't have published
even testimonies for the
church man I I did a deep dive video on
tithe not too long ago um for those that
want to go check that out I went through
all of that stuff and showed exactly
that because they're going to come back
Mike and they're going to say no no no
it's based on the Bible bro yeah I
showed all that and what they're what
they're appealing to is Malachi chapter
3 and they wouldn't be in the
predicament that they're in of tying
being cursed by God if you don't tithe
to the SDA Storehouse that's what they
try to pull out of that is is that it's
applicable to the SDA church and that's
the storehouse and you'll be cursed by
God if you don't they wouldn't be in
that predicament had Ellen White not
given her supposedly divinely inspired
commentary on Malachi chapter 3 tying it
to the New Testament because initially
their system that they came up with
there's nothing wrong with that the
systematic benevolence that they were
coming up with they were basically
fledgling the the system was not going
to be able to last without the financing
that they needed and so they came up
with this systematic benevolence concept
which didn't include tithe at all it was
basically just a new testament idea of
God loves a cheerful giver but that then
evolves because people obviously didn't
just get on board with this this was
done in in the you know behind closed
doors through the leaders and then
brought out to the people and the people
obviously just didn't accept it hookline
and sinker and then oh conveniently
Ellen White gets a vision and now
everyone gets on board that's they have
to get on they have to get on that's
what you're getting well yeah because
that's supposedly God speaking to them
or else you're apostate and you hate the
prophet that it's
just oh dude some of some of the Visions
are just crazy it's like dude are you
serious she claimed to be shown somebody
asked this in the members Q&A the last
one again last one was really good folks
for those that want to check that out
Shameless plug there on the the members
only section you can join that by
clicking the little join button down
below this video you'll have to be on a
desktop computer to do so but Q&A number
seven was it was excellent somebody
asked about this and they said did you
ever hear about Ellen White claiming to
be shown in vision
that some of the people specifically the
men were leaving the camp meeting to go
engage in
self-abuse the phrase that she used to
to talk about oh oh that that Vice that
masturbation Vice that side note just
before you go into that I want to know
how she knew so much about this well
that's what I'm saying you're telling me
God Gave You pornographic Visions that's
essentially what you're saying there's
some people that she's saying this
specific individual God showed me you
left and you went to tug one off like
what so there's just a full gamut there
of like you're getting biblical
commentary but then you're getting like
you said yeah personal rebukes like I
God showed me this like when you had the
the Kur fuffle with the guys that went
and started the messenger party I talk
about that in the tith video as well um
she had all sorts of stuff on them too
there was a lady at the church um the
two guys that that ended up leaving and
became these according to the
organization apostates um and started
the messenger party um there was a Kur
fuffle at one of the churches and then
Ellen came to to clear the air to like
and she's claimed to be shown that oh no
they were the the two gentlemen they
were correct about this debacle with a
lady at one of the churches and then
within less than 24 hours she flip-flops
actually no God showed me she's correct
and you two are actually in the wrong so
she functioned in all sorts of ways
outside of what I think a lot of the
average Adventists is even aware of when
they try to do this sort of like she's
no different than she's no different
than just like Martin Luther or like a
commentator no dude listen she
functioned she is so different than any
other prophet in the Old Testament by
far like she she totally different like
the stuff that she supposedly saw which
I'm convinced that was not from God I
think she did have a you know a special
guide but I don't think it was a guide
from God I think it was something else
yeah easily easily yeah yeah I know it
man well if any you think we're gonna
have anyone show up and defend this
important Three Angels you'd think this
is like one of the most important things
I mean again according to the prophetes
this is the most important message God
has ever given to the world she said and
if any Adventist wants to challenge that
I'm happy to bring up the sources on
such um they're on both our website and
then I can easily access them on the
online Ellen White Library so uh I just
want to remind them again as well that
this is the same woman that said that
Adventists need
to jump at the opportunity to defend
this present truth message with joy and
be able to show us that's what we're
asking is to be shown from scripture
that what the Adventist Church
claims Revelation 14 6-12 is teaching is
indeed what it is teaching because we
are of the opinion and
belief no it is not it's not talking
about seventh day sabari inis the state
of the Dead Health message investigative
judgment young Earth creationism
Darwinism Protestants Roman Catholics
none of that stuff is is what's going on
here and I preferably would love to see
I've been you know I keep getting sda's
Mike that they love to try and Hound me
why don't you bring an admin a scholar
on here folks you need to understand
your champion are not the people you
think they are we have been trying to do
this for at this point years years they
won't they won't they won't even sit
down and just have the discussion I've
asked some of these guys I won't even
all I'm going to do is literally ask
questions we can do it in person I'll
come on my own dime to record it because
I'm trying to appease and just show
people look I'm not just saying this I'm
not just making this up they won't do it
they won't do it so I would love love
for one of them though to come on here
or to sit down and have a discussion and
utilize the hgm for us and come to this
conclusion show us parse out the text
and show us that John writing to his
first second century audience whatever
it was that this is what he he's writing
to them about that there's going to be a
millerite movement that's again the same
thing I did a video on this recently
Revelation 10 9-10 they they claimed
that John eating the scroll and his
stomach becoming bitter was a prophecy
about the millerite movement being
disappointed that the bitterness that
was left in their stomach due to the
prophetic message that is representative
of the scroll that he ate so the so John
in the text is supposed to be a
typological picture of the millerite
movement and the scroll was supposed to
be the special prophetic message that
they had and then when they were
disappointed that's why it was bitter to
John's
stomach y right again please utilize the
hgm for us and show us that you could
ever come to such a conclusion they
won't do it they won't do it so well
they don't want to make themselves look
like idiots which is why and I don't
think they're allowed to if I'm being
very transparent because if they if they
do speak up and they get in a public
forum where they you know disagree then
they're well then their job is gone hey
I don't know how quickly you can uh pull
this up but early
writings yep um I've already got it
right here what page early writings page
258 what par okay I guess the paragraph
doesn't matter you have to tell me it's
literally the the beginning of that
chapter a firm is the chapter on will
yeah on William Miller yeah yeah um I I
just want I want avenus to understand
well I guess those of you that aren't
avist as well um this is not just like
Ellen White claiming something is that
the right one 258
uh I saw who
stood uh we can command F that you're
probably in a different version or at a
different
paragraph yeah different just different
paragraph there you go there you go
there you go yeah yeah yeah this is what
I wanted to to show um this isn't like
Ellen White's interpretation of
something this is literally so important
supposedly to Ellen White that her angel
actually was telling her this is a quote
yeah from her accompanying Angel okay I
saw accompany who stood well guarded and
firm giving no countenance to those who
would unsettle the established faith of
the body God looked upon them with
approbation I was shown three steps well
you could read the Bible and you'd have
them but the first second and third
Angel's messages said my here we go said
my accompanying Angel quote
woe to him who shall move a block or
stir a pin of these
messages the true understanding of these
messages is of vital
importance the destiny of souls hangs
upon the manner in which they are
received this is like this is apparently
so important that it's more important
than you understanding what Christ did
on the cross your soul
hangs in the
balance said her accompanying devil I
mean accompanying angel I'm sorry that
was
a little I'm sorry yeah one blocker pin
is not supposed to be stirred or you
know moved it's just like she says in
that issue of reviewing Herold where
she's like we have the old landmarks of
Truth not a single pillar is supposed to
be altered Etc yeah except you got
things wrong like five times and had to
reimagine things and like reinagle
things and so I know
conveniently well I was just gonna say
miles how how would you if you and I
were to actually test what she teaches
on this how would we be able to properly
test her if whatever she said like you
can't move one pin like you you can't
you can't even test what she's
saying as truth if supposedly her
interpretation that's the problem with
infallible interpreters it it it creates
a I would argue like a reductio ad
absurdum argument you have an infinite
regress of having because then what you
have is you'll get Adventists that tell
you well you have to have an Adventist
there to help you understand the
infallible interpreter who you need to
actually be able to understand the Bible
it just creates this infinite chain of
we have to go here to understand this
and and that's what it ends up resulting
in because at the end of the day and the
only infallible interpreter is the holy
spirit I mean that's the
only yeah it's interesting how many of
their so like it's been a minute since
I've got into this with like my Roman
Catholic friends but this is one of the
things obviously that was debated and
argued in the Reformation was infallible
authorities that's what solos scripture
is actually about it's not saying
tradition doesn't matter it's not saying
the Bible and me under the tree and just
whatever I read and come to like William
Miller did no that's a totally different
concept called nuda scriptura or
biblicism or Bible onlyism which has
every single time without fail folks
every single time go look it up look up
the socinians for example that's who
else the reformers had to deal with in
in their day I was just earlier in
Francis turin's elenctic Theology and
he's talking about the socinians and
refuting the socinians and all of their
stuff was heretical because they had
this Bible only mentality they were like
unitarians they came to all sorts of
wacky conclusions they had a false
gospel and it was just we just believe
the Bible we just read the Bible and the
Bible alone yeah every group that has
done that in history ends up going way
out in left field and ends up espousing
and resurrecting a bunch of ancient
heresy that they think is some
restoration of Truth when it's like no
you're just resurrecting a bunch of
ancient
heresies have you have you heard miles
um so I heard recently I don't know
maybe maybe it's been a month or two ago
I heard someone argue that Adventists
believe in Prima scriptura have you
heard that scriptura yeah which is again
which is again okay
this is just like going back to
discussing with Roman Catholics that's
what Roman Catholics will tell
you oh so so it's identical so they're
like way more like Catholics than they
except here's the thing here's the thing
here's the thing that's different
between they're more insane on this
though than the Roman Catholic position
Adventists in the audience their heads
just exploded yeah it's true the Roman
Catholic Church hasn't been as bold as
the Adventist Church or rather as Ellen
White was in uh essentially giving an
infallible interpretation of any given
passage of the Bible they have a
commentary the Ln SDA Bible commentary
that's what it's called the LNG white
SDA Bible commentary covers Genesis to
Revelation and they view that as
inspired commentary the Roman sea hasn't
the holy sea has not even come close to
to doing such a thing as far as I'm
understand there's only a handful of
passages that they've given infallible
interpretations on so even though they
they claim to have an infallible what
they would call like a three-legged
stool um scripture tradition and and the
magisterium um capital T tradition by
the way not just any tradition but but
the the great tradition um even they
don't make the claim that the SDA church
is so I I commend them for that though
because that's kind of my argument is
like if you have this infallible
interpreter of scripture you should just
give us an infallible interpretation of
the entire book and just there you go
it's it's settled now um if you're going
to claim to to have that and I know that
they have Arguments for at least the
Roman Catholics do for why they have
um but yeah the the SDA Church allegedly
has an infallible interpretation On Any
Given passage of
scripture so yeah they do try to say if
it's infallible why is it so confusing
to me I I don't understand that and it's
just nonsense because it isn't Prima
scriptura it still isn't PR because you
can't you're stuck in a circular problem
I've pointed this out I don't know how
many times in the fundamental beliefs
book they use Uriah Smith's analogy from
the review in Herald where they are
trying to explain in chapter 18 how
Ellen White functions and he explains it
being like a voyage and life is the
parallel to the voyage and on this
Voyage they have a book that gives them
a general overview which is the Bible uh
of the the Journey of life but that book
they claim at the says that at the end
of The Voyage there's going to be
tumultuous times so in the end times
there's going to be a lot of craziness
and and confusion God will then send
forth a pilot and that pilot will be the
one that helps them navigate the
tumultuous times and really be able to
navigate the book and so that's the
problem is okay you have to have this
pilot to be able to actually really
understand what the Bible is saying but
at the same time you just told us that
you found out about the pilot by reading
the
Bible Well you just told us you can't
understand the Bible without the
pilot hello it just it's it's constantly
circular problems that's the problem is
like well it's Prima scriptura well no
it's not because Ellen White's
commentary on the scrip RT is really
what's ultimate because we can't
understand the Bible without that
supposedly we'll come we'll be Babylon
we'll end up being confused
Etc you mentioned earlier unity and
those sorts of things and it's just it's
funny man because it's like I spend a
lot of time in various um typically
depends on the the context I'm I'm
spending a lot of time in in different
Protestant confessions so the reformed
confessions the Lutheran confessions and
then some of the Baptist confessions um
and even the Anglican confessions and
even to some degree Methodist
confessions um they have a little Aster
next to their name regarding
protestantism but nevertheless um it's
like man those confessions are like 95%
in unity that they just word things like
in a different way because at the end of
the day they're typically just restating
things that are found in the Apostles
Creed or the Ning Creed and they're just
expounding upon it with scripture and so
it's like 95% of the stuff in there is
it's 100% on the gospel lit both
objective objectively and subjectively
not just the objective component but
objectively and subjectively unified
across the board regardless of what
confession you read then you even get to
secondary doctrines and yeah I'm aware
of the differences between you know the
christology of the the lutherans over to
say the reformed um regarding the
Eucharist and the Lord's supper and
those types of things but again the
unity far far far outweighs any sort of
division um but they don't understand so
like whenever I bring that up to an
Adventist they'll be like well well look
you guys have separate churches well
right because some of those differences
make their way so for example Baptists
reject infant
baptism that's a part of the church's
liturgy so at my church we do infant
baptisms so Baptists are going to
worship in a different building because
liturgically they're going to have
differences in that area now we can get
into arguing those sorts of things but
the point being is they're still
Christians they're just worshiping in a
different building I was out doing
Street evangelism before doing answering
adventism pretty regularly and I didn't
care regarding the denominational name
of the people I was out there with I
cared that the people that were out
there were were Christians that believed
in the true God and were sharing the
true gospel with people that's what I
cared about I was out there with like a
Pentecostal guy a Lutheran pres a
presbyterian and two
Baptists one of the Baptist guys wasn't
even reformed in traditional Christian I
mean you are unified but I and I say
this
I've said this before
Adventists
adventism the entire framework is almost
like they're a severed appendage to the
body of Christ because they just aren't
UNIF like they are so separate in their
theology that they they can't physically
be United I mean even even their you
know okay there are other Christian
denominations that teach the Sabbath
truth for example like yes okay that's
true um they don't teach it the same way
they don't teach it the same way because
the Adventist understanding of Sabbath
ties to their understanding of
Revelation and the mark of the beast and
the Seal of God and like all of a sudden
now you've just castrated the rest of
you know I mean you you've neutered the
gospels which you've done effectively do
you miles I'm wondering do you have and
I can share my screen if you need me to
do you have the
um do you have the handbook of Seventh
Day Adventist theology perhaps I do what
page would you like um page
886 yeah I cite that book constantly so
I'm gonna bring you up I'm gonna go grab
the physical copy of it and you say to
the audience what you'd like to
say well I uh the the reason why I I and
I I hope the audience um I would
encourage the audience especially if you
are
Adventist um you know even if you're not
you need to get this book because this
is the handbook this is physically what
the Adventist Church teaches
theologically um and so this particular
section is going to be on the remnant
The Three Angels messages uh we probably
don't have enough time to read the first
second and third but I want yes yes I
want to go to the third specifically to
their understanding of the third Angel's
message because page 886 uh I believe
it's 885 886 somewhere in there third
Angel's message yep and the reason why
this is so important is because aanus
have to understand and I'm gonna
actually I'm gonna actually read a very
short quote okay this is from Ellen
White this is from an austral austral
Union Conference record okay yeah and
she says the great final crisis is just
before us it's imminent Jesus is coming
it's great it's imminent right she says
this when the destiny of every human
being will be forever decided a great
work is to be done in setting before men
the saving truths of the Gospel the
present truth the the present these to
sorry to present these truths in the
work
of the third Angel's message the Lord
designed that the presentation of this
message shall be the
highest greatest work carried on in our
world at this time this is literally the
most important thing so I want to go to
what Adventists teach of what it
is which is why I go to the handbook I
don't go to the abous in the Pew because
they're not going to know actually what
they teach to be and I don't mean that
to be sarcastic most aists don't know
what the third Angel's message is in the
aist
framework but if you read through um I
mean the third Angel's
message um do you want me to put this on
the screen by the way
sure uh let
me just want to share your screen and
yeah let me do that uh that way the a
audience can actually see and I have it
highlighted
so
um but this is this is literally the
same exact section that um he was
pulling up this is from uh just so you
can see the handbook of Seventh Day
Adventist theology okay so here you go
you want to know what y'all hey look at
that author LG
white all right um here's what here's
what Adventists understand the
theological understanding of the third
Angel's message finally emerged among
sabbatarian Adventist during the series
of Bible conferences in
1848 as the sanctuary theology
developed they followed Christ by faith
into the most holy place I don't know
how that works how how are they able to
actually follow them into the most holy
place I thought they were sinful people
anyways sorry from Revelation 11:19 they
derive the ability validating uh
validity of God's covenant with its
sacred Arc containing the decalogue
considering Revelation 14:12 as the
central truth of the third Angel's
message they identify the Commandments
of God with the Ten
Commandments in 1846 Joseph Bates
convinced James and Ellen White that the
fourth Commandment should be restored to
the true worship of God Ellen G white
viewed the seventh day Sabbath as the
separating wall this is really this is
her reinterpretation by the way this is
her taking Paul completely out of
context the separating wall between the
true Israel of God and
unbelievers although she acknowledged at
the same time that God had children who
do not see and keep the Sabbath this
concept elevated the Sabbath truth to
the status of a sealing message you want
to know why ainst teach that Sabbath is
the Seal of God it is in their
interpretation of the third Angel's
message and it is stamped and approved
by Ellen G white so you don't have to
believe in her you don't have to even
have her from the
pulpit it's already in the theology if
you're an
avenus or testing Truth for standing
with the remnant Church of Revelation
143 uh 14:12 the faith of Jesus was
interpreted there you go this is their
interpretation as all the teachings of
Jesus in the New Testament or the
precepts and doctrines of the Gospel
although the several years have passed
uh the phrase the testimony of Jesus was
used as a synonym for Faith of Jesus a
new interpretation emerged in the
1980s now the testimony of Jesus was
linked here you go
miles what does that what does that mean
miles uh Jesus is allegedly speaking
through the writings of Ellen White and
therefore they have the testimony of
Jesus because they claim that it's a
prophetic word that will be given to an
end times people where Jesus is uniquely
speaking so this is tied to and whether
or not you believe it or not as an
Adventist okay this is tied to the
Adventist
theology around the third Angel's
message that supposedly is the most
important thing to tell everyone in the
world so if you don't understand the
third Angel's message as an avenus then
you don't understand the importance
inside of your theology and it's all
tied it's all tied to saboten ISM it's
all tied to present truth it's all tied
to Ellen White like you have to accept
her as a
prophet because that that is part of the
linking the the key to the third the
avenus understanding of the third
Angel's message this in
interpretation and I always say this
because avenus do not like to state that
it's their
interpretation it's doesn't mean it's
what the text says it's their
interpretation became an identifying
sign of the remnant Church their church
and was integrated into missionary
proclamation of the Seventh Adventist
Church the interpretation of the beast
in its image there you go again it's all
tied came to be the vital importance for
the understanding of the third Angel's
message in 1851 J and Andrews identified
the
Beast with the Beast of Revelation 13
which was a prophetic development of the
fourth Beast both symbolic beasts of
Daniel 7 and Daniel uh Revelation 13
Ascend out of the sea after listing five
other points of similarity Andre
concluded
quote the Beast is evidently the papal
form of the fourth
Empire and I'll just kind of pause there
for a second um it is really important
for avenus to understand that all of
this like if you don't get this if you
don't understand as avenus how this all
integrates like the third Angel's
message is is supposedly again Ellen
White said it was the most important is
it is more important than anything else
anything else it is the most important
thing it's tied to Sabbath it's tied to
their understanding of the papal power
being the Beast it's their understanding
of I mean Ellen White as a
prophet I know
they everything you can't come to me and
say oh Mike I'm in Avage but I I don't
really I don't read Ellen White I don't
believe like she's really what like I
well then you're not an aous friend
yeah you're Adventist in name
only because you can't have adventism
without her that so many of us have
tried this folks this adventism light is
what I call it it's like well I don't
really accept Ellen no it's a package
deal it's a package deal I can show you
tons of primary sources that say this
it's a package deal you you have to have
it by by rejecting Ellen you're then
also rejecting at the Adventist Church
being the remnant that's supposed to be
part of the identifying mark that
they're the Remnant so if they're not
the remnant well now they've lost this
whole special prophetic end times
identity that we need to come join them
because we're all Babylon the whole
thing collapses you have to have all of
that yeah yeah um Mike did you want to
read anything else from that well and I
was going to turn off the highlights
just to maybe make it a little bit
easier um I just want people to
understand that Andrews and Bates like
if if you don't like if you're an avenus
and you haven't
studied what Andrews and Bates and Ellen
White and all the Pioneers like the
importance of what they played in your
the even if you don't agree even if you
don't think Ellen White is X Y and
Z you need to understand where your
theology actually came from yep that's
my challenge to any AVST that's watching
this right now like if you haven't
studied this I would say don't get into
debates online about your theology your
aist theology without studying this
stuff because th this is this is what
you and I are engaging in this is what
we go to this is why we say what we say
it's not what is in the pews of the
Adventist Church and we're not
condemning
Adventists this is this is us talking
about the theological system of the
ainst church and quite frankly um I I
created I won't show you this but I
created a special highlight liting palet
in my study of adventism and I have a
very special one that's called
heresy it literally says heresy and the
number of times that I use that tool
because it they teach a different gospel
it is a totally different
approach to the work of Christ the
importance of what we're supposed to be
doing in the end times we are not
supposed to be converting people into
Adventists
that is not the function of the third
Angel's
message from a Biblical standpoint yeah
they'll tell you the third Angels
messages is about warning the world
about Satan's
deceptions no that that's not the gospel
the gospel is not warning people about
Satan's deceptions no already a defeated
foe yes good the gospel means good news
it's a message of good news about who
Christ is and what Christ accomplished
that's the gospel
not warning not about Satan not warning
people about Satan that there's a
deceiver this all gets into Mike the the
the Paradigm of like I honestly just I
pity Adventists who they constantly
hammer on things like the mark of the
beast Etc and you'll hear them say well
because you don't want to be deceived in
the end that just presupposes a very
weak God a god who's constantly testing
you like I'm going to see if you're
going to really be able that's not the
god of the the Bible the god of the
Bible keeps his people he protects his
people I'm not worried about being
deceived in the end because I trust God
and I trust God's protection I trust
Jesus's own words um I hear the
shepherd's voice and I follow him I'm
not but this all gets birth out of the
great disappointment and oh the
millerite chart was a test from God and
the Sabbath is a test from God and
you're on probation and all these things
are are like Ste all fear mongering it's
all fear based and interestingly it's
all rooted back into keeping you tied to
the Adventist
organization yes if you want to remain
safe stay in the organization don't look
outside the organization don't question
things outside the organization or or
question things within the organization
about people outside the organization
and what they're saying Etc yeah so M
miles before I unshare my screen this is
just the third Angel's message I want
all of all of my Adventist friends that
are watching right now that say I don't
I like my pastor doesn't preach Len I
don't what okay this is the handbook on
avenus theology that you're looking at
this is what you're supposed to believe
okay I want you to notice the number of
Bible texts versus Ellen White quotes as
I scroll through here Revelation
Revelation Ellen White Revelation
Revelation just just start to look
there's there's Bible quotes here but
then when we get into interpretation we
have this is
reviews yeah no that's lero F's
prophetic Faith of Our Fathers
y Ellen
White here's Nicholls who is a good
friend I mean I think idolized Ellen
White testimony midcentury SDA apolog
just you go through here and you can't
say that I'm an Adventist and I don't I
don't believe XY andz about Ellen White
the church believes she's a prophet the
church uses her as interpret I'm going
to show this again one more time okay I
want you to
notice Handbook of seventh day AVST
theology author Len G white published
by th this is yes I there is another
individual here there's r deran that was
the individual that wrote all the other
stuff but you got to understand the
Adventist Church understands Ellen
White's role as The
Interpreter I mean it's in their
handbook well not just that Mike but
literally at the end of every chapter so
I have the one here from from
2000 um and at the end of every single
chapter so here for example the one on
Revelation and inspiration I I cite this
chapter a lot probably the the most out
of this this book because that's the
subject that we're on this one was
written by another individual who I cite
pretty frequently uh former Professor
rep at Andrews Peter Van bmlin I cite
his paper on justification by faith and
Advent understanding all the time time
at the end of this chapter what's the
final section in every single one of
these chapters I'm gonna read it for you
folks it's it's all Ellen White Ellen G
white's comments and it's a section how
Ellen White's comments and quotes Christ
object lessons great controversy great
controversy great controversy
testimonies for the church Volume 5
medical Ministry Christ object lessons
early writings evangelism testimonies
for the church volume Five again it's
just constant over and over uh Christ
object lessons Len white SDA Bible
commentary volume 7 volume uh
testimonies for the church volume six
great controversy great
controversy uh steps to Christ just over
and over and over again every one of
these chapters ends with them showing
the spirit of Prophecy supports what's
being put forth in this because it has
to yep because it has to I mean you can
see it you can see it right here LG
white comment if you go to another
section down here L white comments the
every chapter hey I had I had to show
this real quick I I want to get your
opinion on how you feel about this this
is right after her uh comments how do
you feel that they quote your one of
your favorite the theologians yeah they
do that a lot man they they site sha for
example I love sha I'm a big I'm a big
fan of them Merc they use individuals
that don't even believe what they
believe but they they they try to do
that man and I talk about this a lot too
they try to do this to add like
theological street cred to their
theology so like they'll cite a person
like in in every one of the sections
they also have a section where they try
to do like an overview of throughout
history here's how it's been understood
by various people so they do that too
and then they they end after that with
the section that says the Adventist
understanding so every historical
revisionism right it's that like
throughout history this is the way it's
been understood but now we are here to
show you sometimes like see you see
there that the source under be they're
citing FF Bruce um who's obviously known
in the textual critical World um and
they they'll sometimes cite them for
like okay yeah cool like you're you're
showing that this is like scholastically
agreed upon or like something like that
okay yeah I get that but they will
sometimes cite individuals like they do
this with shaf a lot um at Le especially
the SDA Pioneers just had a video on
this this past week where jayen Andrews
is trying to appeal to shock
and it's like yet you're coming to
conclusions that scha directly says you
shouldn't come to based on he was
appealing to Constantine and trying to
say that Constantine as a heathen laid
the framework for Sunday to take on
sabatical characteristics and then Pope
Sylvester came along and he's the one
that introduced it formally into the
Christian Church um deceptively under
the term Lord's day and it's like well
if then you go and read schaf and his
entire chapter on this and he's like you
can't overplay what Constantine did the
church was already he said the the
practice of first day worship goes back
to the apostles it was around long
before Constantine so it's just like
they'll site them when they they think
it's convenient um but then they won't
in in other instances and you'll get
them trying to make that same argument
back to you where they'll try to do
stuff like well you site people
sometimes and you only site them when
they agree with you but it depends why
you're citing the source that that
matters that that matters yeah I'm I
this is one of the reasons why I mean I
I I write a lot on on my blog and I I do
that because I want people to have the
entire context of why I'm saying what
I'm saying and what what what I'm
referencing and what is my line of
thinking um partly because I find it
very complicated to debate with avenus
because they're all over the place so if
you just have here here's my stance you
need to read the article but when I went
to the very first um there there's a
conference called the conference it's
the Society of biblical literature
conference and I ran into a a scholar
that I had become friends with um and
I'll leave her name out it's not
important um but when I was dial she
when I met her inside the big Expo area
where all the books and all the
Publishers and all the you know you know
ivp and erman's and like all the you
know all the Publishers in the academic
world um she had found a book that she
was quoting in and she went to it and
she was reading it and she said wow it's
great that I was quoted but
man he quoted something I don't even
like he used it in a way like that I
don't even believe what it is that he's
saying but he used me in a way that like
this is this happens across the board
yeah and it's actually my big fear yeah
it's my big fear putting something out
there and then someone's going to use it
in a way that like weaponizes something
against my way of
understanding and so it is common and
it's but it is something that I think I
would encourage those watching when
you're reading something if you're going
to honor even what AVST believe if
you're going to honor what it actually
is you need to do the work and actually
read what it is that your denomination
actually teaches don't take what your
pastor says don't take what your friend
says don't like read it and work it out
and flesh it out and try to understand
why it is that they have The Stance that
they have that's the reason why my wife
and I and my family left the church
because when we did the heavy lifting
and work we didn't agree with where they
landed
theologically yeah and to be fair there
are some things like you'll never see me
site some of the things I'm fully aware
of I've been doing this long enough now
I know so for example there's some
citations that people will appeal to and
say look at Ellen White's racism
yet if you actually go to the source no
you you're actually abusing it so there
are times where that even happens yes in
that direction um but I have found for
example and I've brought this Source up
before um the last time I brought it up
was when we were looking at step bore
talk about the time of trouble and
probation um and I showed how in one
issue of ministry magazine SDA
Theologian Roy gain tried arguing that
Martin Luther early Martin Luther and
John Calvin support the Advent
understanding of
justification that justification and
sanctification are intermingled that
they're tied together so intrinsically
that you can't have one without the
other well he cited from Calvin's
institutes which I have and have read
quite a bit of um coming from the
reformed tradition and he literally
quotes he pulls a quote from when Calvin
is steelmanning the position he's
arguing against and then attributes that
to John Calvin
Calvin's literally arguing against the
position that Roy gain is seeking to
defend but he he either unknowingly or
who knows he quotes from Calvin's book
three of his institutes where he's
steelmanning the position that he's
about to decimate and disagree with but
cites it as though Calvin is agreeing
with him see I I want to give someone
like that the benefit of the doubt but
in Academia this stuff is supposed to be
peer reviewed and like this that's
unacceptable that is that not be allowed
by the publisher and I showed it on
stream we went through I was like folks
it's going to be a lot of reading but
we're going to work through this here so
you can see that this guy doesn't know
what he's talking about and then this is
published actually I think it was
actually in Ministry magazine I can't
remember it's either Ministry or review
and Herald um either way the the point
being is it was published in an official
publishing arm of the SDA church was
then blasted out to other people who who
knows how many people read this and now
I see people parir at this my in the
comments of of my videos all the time
I've had people whenever I make videos
about justification our views the same
as Luther and John Calvin no it isn't no
it isn't not at all your guys's view is
late medieval it's a late medieval view
it's not it's the exact thing that the
reformers were saying is detracting away
from what is patristic but nevertheless
um Mike have you you mentioned earlier
this has been sitting on my mind because
you mentioned when you were reading from
the uh I think it was from the handbook
uh you mentioned the ceiling message
I'll have a question for you this could
be informative as well for the audience
are you aware that there's actually some
Nuance to the ceiling
message I it would not surprise me I
haven't studied it in Great depth so fun
fact for people you have to be careful
when you read in SDA sources especially
early SDA sources and you come across
ceiling because there is some
distinction so let's go over this a
little bit just for uh information's
sake to get people caught up to speed
here so this is from an article on our
website what is the ceiling message in
adventism okay the concept or topic of
cealing is C is a central aspect of
Seventh Day Adventist theology but it's
important to understand there are two
contexts in which this can be referring
and it's easy to confuse the two
especially as it pertains to SDA history
so the first one the cealing message of
the 144,000
in 1916 this is the year after Ellen
White dies which actually is important
in the context of this discussion if you
want to get deep in it SDA Pioneer JN
labero published a little booklet titled
questions on the ceiling message which
sought to answer questions as it
pertains to the ceiling of the 144,000
mentioned in Revelation this is after
years of confusion over this matter the
preceding decades due to Len G white's
visions
so he writes in here quote in reference
to the subject matter of this book the
sealed 144,000 I've been greatly moved
by the spirit of God to write and
publish the facts as to how the seing
message was obtained not only from the
Bible but what
Mike you're one and only sister but by
direct instruction in visions of sister
EG white also as to how the message was
received and taught by our ministers and
people down to the year 1894 when the
new light Theory found its advocate in
one who afterwards apostatized from the
faith and died without seeing the
Fulfillment of his expectation that he
would live to the end of time and hence
be one of the
144,000 his claim was that later
testimonies of sister white taught that
all the 144,000 would be made up of
those who had never
died when I found that some were
teaching that all of the 144,000 who
will be sealed are now living I thought
it time that someone should speak and
show that this is not the manner of
God's prophets to make positive
statements at one time and afterwards
teach entirely contrary to them oh how
ironic such surely was not the course of
Bible prophets the whole of this new
light is produced by taking words out of
their connection AKA context and away
from the things of which they are spoken
and giving them a General application as
you will see when we come to the
analysis of the matter close quote as
lboro notes Ellen White's Visions played
a role in influencing varying
understandings of the ceiling message
and led to the charge that certain
individuals were misinterpreting and
misusing Ellen's Visions to support
their new light on the subject wherein
laborough sought to disprove these
individuals and their theories but he
also notes how the SDA church was
reluctant to officially publish on the
subject in their Publications so he
sought to do it himself
not a good idea quote I presented the
substance of this tract in two
discourses on the Stockon Campground
those who heard the discourses requested
that it might be published so that they
could have the reading of it as the
subject is one on which there is some
controversy I thought our Publishers
would not wish to print the matter in
their papers or take the responsibility
of publishing it in any form close quote
he then explains what is uh what the
commonly held belief on the subject
amongst Adventists was until 1894 so
catch
that he explains until 1894 there was a
certain understanding around the 144,000
and the ceiling message if you read
modern SDA scholarship on the 144,000
they're going to try and tell you stuff
like they never firmly said it was going
to be anything specific outside of just
a general idea of a group of people that
are whoever it is that's alive at the
second coming but
Loney quote I will quote from a track
published in 1852 a vision given to
Sister
white ah there it is again at the home
of brother Harris at Centerport New York
August 24 1850 quote I saw that Satan
will work now more powerfully than ever
before more powerfully than ever before
Satan was working against this concept
of the ceiling message of the 144,000
that they were teaching ing prior to
1894 for he knows that his time is short
and that the ceiling will soon be
over soon be
over
1852 and he will now work in every in uh
insinuation to get the Saints off their
guard and get them to sleep upon present
truth and doubting it so as to present
their being sealed with the Seal of the
Living God we read in early writings
experience and Views page 49 in the old
Edition the cealing time is very short
and soon will be over now is the time
while the four angels are holding the
four wins to make our calling and
election sure
pause perfect example I cite this quote
periodically on here that he's referring
to that's seen in experience and Views
where she says the ceiling is almost
over time is short Etc I've seen people
for example cite this and they mean well
but they're wrong they'll cite this to
say look they said that the the mark of
the beast in the ceiling of the the law
and the the fourth Commandment the
Sabbath was taking place back then no
that's not what they're talking about
here they're talking about a different
thing in this context okay so if you see
that experience in views page 49 quote
Etc where she says time is short I saw
that the ceiling time was almost up this
is what she is referring to
okay he continues it was because of the
these plain statements that our people
and ministers down to 1894 believed and
taught that the cealing work had been
going on since
1848 and that the 144,000 were being
sealed I do not see how we could draw
any other idea from the testimonies we
have quoted that the ceiling work had
begun in 1848 to
1850 close quote that is the further
evidence for you folks that this is
different than the ceiling of the
Sabbath because at this time 1848 and
1850 they're not even completely firmed
up on the Sabbath yet they haven't even
had Allen hasn't even had uh I need to
check the dates on this but if I
remember correctly she hasn't even had
her her revised vision of when she's
taken to heaven and seen the Arc of the
Covenant with the I'm pretty sure that
happened in
1852 I could be wrong but um
nevertheless the point being is there's
a different ceiling going on here due to
the very clear plethora of statements
made by Ellen White from Visions Laur
recognized that the ceiling work began
between 1848 and 1850 and Adventists
believed that work had been going on
since then until
1894 the claim was being made that the
only ones that would be among the sealed
144,000 are those who live until
Christ's actual second coming this led
to the question what about those who had
died during this ceiling
period laor Then speaks to this after
referencing a number of Len white quotes
he says quote if there is still a doubt
of the resurrected Sabbath Keepers being
numbered with the 144,000 consider the
following from Sister White's words in
1909 so again he's jumped ahead here
he's not talking here about 1848 to 1850
like we just were so when he talks about
the sealed Sabbath Keepers here he's
talking about later on past all that at
the general conference in 1909 Elder
Irwin had a stenographer accompany him
in a call upon sister white he wished to
ask her some questions and have an exact
copy of the words of the question
questions and the exact words of the
replies among other questions was this
one will those who have died in the
message be among the 144,000 in reply
sister white said oh yes those who have
died in the faith will be among the
144,000 I am clear on that
matter these were the exact words of
question and answer as brother Irwin
permitted me to copy from his
stenographers
report even until 1916 there was great
confusion over the subject within 7th
Day adventism which explains why lbo
himself was confused on the subject
throughout the book he seems to put
forth the idea that the ceiling message
came around between 1848 and 1850 with
his proof being a vision from Ellen
White in
1849 but he failed to reference Ellen
White's first alleged Vision in 1844
which clearly references this but notes
something interesting ah so we get the
path Vision it always goes back to the
path Vision December number 1844 I'm not
going to read the whole thing here but
here it is notice the final paragraph
that we have on on the page quote is
talking about those who believed the
message but then came around and said
okay actually nothing actually happened
probably in 1844 I'm going to go back to
being a Baptist these people are the
ones who fell off the path they fell all
the way along the path one after another
until we heard the voice of God like
many Waters which gave us the day and
hour of Jesus is coming the living
Saints 144,000 in number knew and
understood the voice while the wicked
thought it was Thunder and an earthquake
when God spake the time he poured on us
the Holy Ghost and our faces began to
light up and shine with the glory of God
as Moses has did when he came down from
Mount
Si in this Vision she claimed to be
shown a number of things but two in
particular regarding the ceiling message
that the 144,000 is an actual number and
that they're the living
Saints this same thing was reiterated in
an alleged vision from 1847 which is
documented in the word of the little
clock where she said quote the living
Saints 144,000 in number knew and
understood the voice while the wicked
thought it was Thunder and an earthquake
she's essentially reiterating the same
thing she just said in early writings by
this time the 144,000 were all sealed
and perfectly United on their foreheads
was written God New Jerusalem and a
glorious star containing Jesus's new
name then Jesus's silver trumpet sounded
oh like the angel Moroni in Mormonism
has that silver trumpet as he descended
Ed on the ground wrapped in flames of
fire he gazed on the graves of the
sleeping Saints then raised his eyes and
hands to heaven and cried out awake
awake awake ye that sleep in the dust
and arise Mike if you didn't know Jesus
apparently speaks in Old English the
Queens English there was a mighty
earthquake the graves opened and the
dead came up clothed with immortality
the 144,000 shouted Hallelujah as they
recognized their friends who had been
torn from them by death and in the same
moment we were changed and caught up
together with them to meet the Lord in
the air ah the 144,000 is
alive very clearly Ellen White believed
the 144,000 would be alive to witness
these things occur with the sealing
process already underway and the sealed
144,000 would be alive to witness the
resurrection in the same vision from
early writings she claimed that after
being shown these things the angel told
her that she should go back to Earth and
that if she was faithful her along with
the 144,000 would have the privilege of
visiting all the other worlds that God
had created to see his handiwork Mike
this is getting back into what I was
asking you about earlier about the
second and or the special
Resurrection this was supposed to be for
this 144,000 that was heralding this
most important message ever given to the
world at the end of time but as you can
see in this quote here folks can go
check out all the stuff on folks that's
in red on here on our website is
hyperlink click on this it'll take you
you can read to your heart Hearts
content but notice she was told
supposedly in this Vision after being
shown heaven you must go back and if
you're faithful you with the 144,000
shall have the
privilege of visiting all the worlds and
viewing the handiwork of God she
apparently saw Enoch on another world
who had been translated where she asked
him if the world she saw was the
Heavenly City to which he said no he was
simply traveling to this world to which
Ellen begged her angel messenger that
she wanted to stay and leads the angel
telling her that she had to go back
remain faithful and if she did her and
the 144,000 would have their privilege
of returning again evidencing that the
144,000 was understood to be a literal
number who would be living Saints like
she said earlier she continued by saying
that this ceiling time was soon to be
over because it was very short this was
in 1849 mind you so here's the quote in
early writings as well as experience and
Views that I was talking about where she
says my dear brothers and sisters let
the Commandments of God and the
testimony of Jesus Christ be in your
minds continually Mike already showed
you earlier what the testimony of Jesus
Christ
is and let them crowd out worldly
thoughts and cares when you lie down and
when you rise up let them be your
meditation live and act wholly in
reference to the coming of the son of
man the ceiling time is very short and
will soon be over now is the time while
the four angels are holding the Four
Winds to make our calling and election
sure close quote which means it was
understood that the 144,000 of living
Saints would be reached in their
lifetime since Christ hadn't returned
yet or hasn't returned yet this has
morphed into very short being redefined
as70 plus years later fast forward to
1850 in a letter that Ellen White wrote
to an Adventist Mr Hastings that was
grieving the loss of his wife where
Ellen White writes in part quote I saw
ah envision she was sealed and would
come up at the voice of God and stand
upon the Earth and would be with the
144,000 I saw we need not mourn for her
she would rest in the time of trouble
and all that we could mourn for was our
loss of being deprived of her company I
saw her death would result in good close
quote now we see a transition from the
144,000 being living saints that will
witness those coming up from the grave
to including some who are um some of
those who have been sealed and died Mrs
Hastings who was deceased was allegedly
a part of the
144,000 in his book JN laber points out
how Adventist of the day loved to point
to a citation from the great controversy
where Ellen White states that the living
saints that make up the 144,000 would be
the ones who passed through the time of
Jacob's trouble and have stood without
an intercessor quote these are they
which came out of the Great Tribulation
they've passed through the time of
trouble such as never was since there
was a nation they have endured the Ang
anguish of time of Jacob's trouble
they've stood without an intercessor
through the final outpouring of God's
judgment but they've been delivered for
they've washed their robes and made them
white in the blood of the Lamb close
quote this would be cited by Adventists
to state that clearly Ellen White taught
that all the 144,000 would be alive
jumping ahead to
1901 the Adventists were still perplexed
as to if they could be one of the
144,000 what Ellen White really believed
and taught Etc we read and selected
messages book one so sdas were confused
on this they were like what's the truth
about the 144,000 and it kept is it
people who are all of them are going to
be alive because the ceiling is already
started oh but now it's some people are
going to be part of it who have died but
they're going to be raised to be with
the 144,000 so they're all confused
because they're appealing to Ellen
White's Visions on this so Ellen
documents this or it's pulled in the
compilation book of selected messages
book one quote Christ says that there
will be those in the church who will
present fables and supposition itions
when God has given Grand elevating en
nobling truths which should ever be kept
in the Treasure House of the bind when
men pick up this Theory and that theory
when they are curious to know something
is not necessary for them to know God is
not leading them it's not his plan that
his people shall present something which
they have to suppose which is not taught
in the word my the irony it's not his
will that they shall get into
controversy over questions which will
not help them spiritually such as who's
to compose the
144,000 this those who are the elect of
God will be in a short time know without
question close quote so by this point
she's saying that it isn't God's will
for people to inquire about these
matters such as if they are a part of
the 144,000 as it's not going to help
them spiritually but in a short time
those who are the elect of God will know
without question but then four years
later in a sermon that she gives in 1905
she exhorts Adventist to strive with all
power that God has given them to be
among the 144,000 or she said quote this
is in review and Herald let us strive
with all the power that God has given us
to be among the
144,000 and let us do all that we can to
help others to gain heaven we are to
have an intense interest in Christ Jesus
for he is our savior he came to this
world to be tempted in all points as we
are to prove to the universe that in
this world of sin human beings can live
lives that God will approve AKA they can
keep the law close quote is it any
wonder that at that sdas who looked to
Ellen White for guidance were confused
on the one hand they were being told to
not get bogged down in matters of who is
and isn't part of the 144,000 and
instead focus on T the tasks at hand
while on the other she sang to strive
with all power to make sure you were
among the 144,000 but remember what laor
documented regarding the 1909 General
Conference session where he examined the
transcript of the stenographer alen
white said oh yes those who have died in
the faith will be among the 144,000 I'm
clear on this matter which explains why
there was such confusion amongst the
early Adventists over this matter Ellen
White herself was
confused then you also have the Sabbath
seal which again is obviously very short
because we have other articles on this
the Sabbath seal the second area of
ceiling is a matter entirely distinct
from this cealing message referred to by
laor and has to do with the Seal of
God's law being contained within the
fourth Commandment of the Ten
Commandments given to those in the end
times who keep the Commandments of God
and have the faith of Jesus do not
confuse these two cealing events so Mike
I'm not sure if you were aware of all of
this I don't know if you were expecting
me to go in on all of that but just an
FYI for you that you when you read about
the ceiling in adventism um it is a mess
it is a mess depending on what period of
time you're pulling from it was an Ever
revolving
door yeah I mean I as you were reading
through that it's like at one point it's
like okay so I understand what she's
saying and then all of a sudden it's
entirely different and it's a different
direction and she's got to like cover
what she said before and I really was
taken back by your comment in uh in
great controver everyone thinks that
great controversy is like one of these
amazing books it's probably one of the
most heretical books out there that
she's written but the fact that she
literally says they have stood without
an intercessor through the final
outpouring of God's judgment friends
that is
heresy that that is the mo one of the
most unbiblical statements that you can
possibly make I don't care if you think
her books have some wonderful stuff in
it and whatever like one bit of heresy
would deem a person unfit as a prophet
like that statement makes me
mad that that is that's horrible to
teach that kind of junk it's horrible
it's it's entirely unbiblical and and
it's not me saying that it's unbiblical
I'm I'm glad you're bringing it up I
mean this is you even said this we were
watching a video that that you were
doing early on uh just earlier today
about this entire you know process in
are you in Hebrews yeah Hebrews 7
explicitly contradicts the text the
gymnastics the Adventists will go
through to defend this is just insane so
you're telling me there's going to be
sin forever because Jesus is no friend
that just evidences you don't understand
the intercession of Christ that's all
that shows because the text verbatim
says this the text verbatim says this
the Salter foretold of this and the
entire point that the author is making
throughout the whole book of Hebrews but
specifically in chapter 7 is how Jesus
is a better priest than the Levites and
and I want to use the the statement that
my AVST friends like to say this is the
plain reading of the text like this
isn't complicated okay no he says his
whole point here is again how Jesus is
different how the melchisedek and order
is different than the levitical order
and how it's Superior and part of why
it's Superior is because Jesus has an
indestructible life the fact that the
Levites had to keep doing stuff over and
over and over so repetitive sacrifices
as well as new priests because one would
die and a new one would have to be
chosen that was evidence that it
couldn't perfect a person it was
imperfect that's why it had to keep
happening over and over and over and
over again so his whole point about how
Jesus is better part of that is because
he has an indestructible life but why
does why does him having an
indestructible life tie into his
priesthood the former priest on the one
hand existed in greater numbers so there
were multiple of them because they were
prevented by Death from
continuing Jesus on the other hand
because he continues forever he he has
an indestructible life he'll live
forever holds his priesthood how long
Mike
forever
permanently forever that's the plain
reading of the text my friend no
gymnastics that's just what the words
say don't tell me you just believe the
Bible yet you're going to stand by great
controversy where the text text
explicitly says he's going to hold his
priesthood permanently because it's tied
to his kingship as well malkis DEC at
the very beginning of the book avenus
don't pay attention to
this for this mzc he actually starts
back in chapter nine he says he's
entered behind the veil after the order
of melchisedek for this
melchisedek king of
Salem priest of the most high God
simultaneous role not he's he was a
priest and then he stopped at a later
point and put on kingly garments and
then be started the work of a king at
that point no no he was a priest king
this is another way that Jesus in the
melkisedek in order differ from the
levitical priests they were not Kings
they were only priests they didn't have
a throne to sit on in the the temple
they were always standing because they
were always dealing with sin the work
was never finished Jesus is seated
because he's a king and the work is
finished nevertheless again continuing
with what he said
before he quotes from the Salter verse
17 you're a priest forever forever he
holds his priesthood
permanently therefore so because he
holds it pre permanently and he's kept
from dying because of his indestructible
life he's also able to save forever
those who come to God through him since
he how long
mike always lives forever in perpetuity
he never ceases to intercede for us
he holds his priesthood permanently
he'll be a priest forever he always
lives to make intercession for them the
Adventist Church is wrong friend it's
not the Bible That's wrong it's not this
should cause an Adventist to go oh wow
adventism is wrong but instead they'll
dig their heels in and say okay I have
to find a way to make this obscure and
not mean what it says so you're saying
sin will exist forever no that just
shows you don't understand what's going
on in this text it just shows you don't
understand the priesthood of Christ
it shows you need to go back to Bible
basics and you need to re rethink some
things they don't understand the
intercession of Christ that's the
problem they're thinking of Christ in
the levitical order they'll tell you
they'll pay lip service to say well
Jesus is after the order of
melchisedek okay well then you need to
understand what that means it means he's
a priest king it means he's going to be
a priest king forever however long he's
going to be a priest and however long he
lives or however long he's going to be a
king and however long he lives that's
how long he's going to also be a priest
he's never going to cease doing that
because this is tied to the
Incarnation he's not a levite but they
that that shows that again all their
defenses to Ellen White being shown in
Vision that he's wearing levitical
priesthood garments and he's up in
heaven well no no no that was just Roy
gain says no no that was just a picture
to show us that he's functioning as a
priest he's not literally wearing
levitical priesthood garments we know
he's after the order of
melchisedec okay well then Adventists
need to understand he's never going to
stop being a priest then because that's
consistent with the mchis edian order
you're thinking they're thinking about
him like a levitical
priest so the the the big quote that we
started out with um with regards to John
Pauline um and a different gospel I
would I would
posit that the Adventist
gospel has a version
where the priest is Jesus let's forget
about the levite and M let's just leave
that out for a second whatever you okay
I'll just give that to you okay but this
priest ceases to mediate at some
point like this is the version of the
ainst gospel and I this isn't me saying
it like I don't think this is and you
could probably you might know this off
the top of your head miles but this is
not the only statement that she made
you know in great controversy where she
says that they stood without an
intercessor this is not the only place
this is not like some obscure thing this
is a part of the teaching of the Gospel
of the Adventist Church that you will
have to stand before an almighty god
without an intercessor while he's
changed his
clothes I don't know how that works as
an almighty God like all it's just
representative of a change of function
it's not a representative of him
literally changing garments that's the
argument oh well because she says they
have stood without an
intercessor so I don't know how I don't
like here's what's funny to me miles
like Ellen White's writings are written
in English you don't have to translate
it like yeah and not oh it's a confusion
third grade educated English yeah I mean
there's nothing else that it can mean
it's not like oh forgot she was writing
in like Portuguese and I mistranslated
it in some way no she says they speaking
of the 144,000 here okay they have stood
without an intercessor through the final
outpouring of God's judgment they they
stood without an
intercessor so friend if you're an ainst
and you're watching the Adventist gospel
that John paulan correctly States is a
different gospel
has Jesus
functioning as an intercessor and then
gives up that function where you have to
stand before an almighty god without his
righteousness yeah I would freak out if
I was an avenus right now yeah and for
those that do not know this the reason
that this is such a big sticking point
is because of and it all goes back to
the Crux of the great controversy
Paradigm which is that God is on trial
his law is in question and he's
vindicating such from the accusations of
Satan and that's part of how that
happens so let's go over this a little
bit Mike because I think people in the
audience would find this um fascinating
I don't think we're going to get any AD
which I didn't while pulling that up
while you're pulling that up it always
irritates me that people that us mere
humans think that God's the one on trial
yeah
ridiculous
so all right she titles this
in I'm gonna go Christ in his Sanctuary
because that's where it conveniently
gets piled together but she titles this
in Christ in his sanctuary as the
courtroom scene so if you read this
chapter I believe it's chapter nine
we're going to see here in a moment when
I get it brought up
it is starting on page
178 gosh the interface on here there we
go all right so let's read through some
of this here let me actually turn dark
reader on as well
okay all
right so here's the courtroom
scene
okay this is after the close of the
investigative judgment pH folks this is
when so Christ is going to cease being a
mediator once the investigative judgment
closes that's the claim okay then this
courtroom scene is going to happen this
is what's going to be taking place in
heaven while the time of trouble is
going on on the earth okay notice what
she says here we're going to read a bit
of
this the deepest interest manifested
among men in the decisions of Earthly
tribunals but faintly represents the
interest EV uh evinced in the Heavenly
courts when the names entered in the
books of Life come up in review before
the judge of all the Earth the Divine
intercessor presents The Plea that all
who have overcome through faith in his
blood so one thing to note here folks
they distinguish between intercessor and
mediator
okay the Divine intercessor presents The
Plea of all who have overcome through
faith in his blood be forgiven their
transgressions so who's that
Mike well who do you think it is that's
the people that made it through the
investigative judgment
okay this madeup construct by the way so
after the people who made it through the
judgment and didn't have their names
blotted out of the book Jesus Will
present their case Before He'll be
advocating for those individuals
okay miles before you go on this is the
reason why why when I was in
adventism I never really
could have the
assurance that I was saved because of
the investigator because like I didn't
know if I was going to like if I had
done enough or if I had whatever it like
this whole investigative judgment
concept is such a I'm G to say it's a
cultic
hook to keep people tied into adventism
because it is SC like if you really buy
into this
concept it is scary to think outside of
it like except for duded except for the
diluted people who think that they're
sinless perfect and they're so holy they
glow in the dark and they're they're
going to pass with flying colors that
crowd but she
continues the Divine intercessor
presents The Plea that all who have
overcome through faith in his blood be
forgiven their transgressions that they
be restored to their Eden home and
crowned as joint heirs with himself to
the first Dominion Micah
48 Satan in his efforts to deceive and
tempt our race had thought to frustrate
the divine plan in man's creation but
Christ now asks that this plan be
carried into effect as if man had never
fallen
so Satan's going to be making a case
Jesus is going to be making a
case he asks for his people not only
pardon and justification full and
complete but a share in his glory and a
seat upon his throne there's their final
eschatological second tier of
justification coming through as
well while Jesus is pleading for the
subjects of his grace Satan accuses them
before God as
transgressors The Great Deceiver has
sought to lead them into skep skepticism
to cause them to lose confidence in God
to separate themselves from his love and
to break his law now he points to the
record of their lives to the defects of
character the unlike uh the unlikeness
of Christ which has Dishonored their
redeemer to all the sins that he has
tempted them to commit and because of
these he claims them as his
subjects Jesus does not excuse their
sins but shows their penitence in faith
and claiming for them forgiveness he
lifts his wounded hands before the
father and the Holy Angel say saying I
know them by name I've Graven them on
the palms of my hand the sacrifices of
God are a broken Spirit a broken and
contrite heart oh God thou wil not
despise Psalm 51:17 it's just so funny
how they're like look she cites the
Bible so she because she just randomly
cites proof text periodically that's
just supposed to demonstrate that this
is you know biblically supported or
anything and to the accuser of his
people he declares the Lord rebuke thee
Oh Satan even the Lord that hath chosen
Jerusalem rebuke thee is not this a
brand plucked out of the fire Zechariah
3:2 Christ will clothe his faithful ones
with his own righteousness that he may
present them to his father a glorious
church not having spot or wrinkle or any
such thing Ephesians 5:27 their names
stand enrolled in The Book of Life and
concerning them it is written they shall
walk with me in white for they are
worthy Revelation 3:4 thus will be
realized the complete fulfillment of the
New Covenant promise catch
this I will forgive their iniquity and I
will remember their sin no
more that's only a reality at the point
of this going on it's not a reality
right
now in those days and in that time
sayeth the Lord the iniquity of Israel
shall be sought for and there shall be
none and the sins of Jo of Judah and
they shall not be found Jeremiah 31:34
and 5020 in that day shall the branch of
the Lord be benefit beautiful and
glorious and the fruit of the Earth
shall be excellent and and comely for
them that have es uh that are escaped of
Israel and it shall come to pass that he
that is left in Zion and he that
remaineth in Jerusalem Shall be Called
holy even everyone that is written among
the living in Jerusalem Isaiah 42-3 man
look at Mike look at all that biblical
support you just sprinkle in a bunch of
look at all that hgm going on look at it
yeah I know you just sprink in a bunch
of verses and it just all supports
whatever it is that you're saying the
work of the investigative judgment and
the blotting out of sins is to be
accomplished before the second Advent of
the Lord since the dead are to be judged
out of the things written in the books
it is impossible that the sins of men
should be blotted out until after the
Judgment at which their cases are to be
investigated but the Apostle Peter
distinctly states that the sins of
Believers will be blotted out when the
times of refreshing shall come from the
presence of the Lord and He Shall send
Jesus Christ acts 3:19 and 20 yeah so
when Peter was preaching about on
Pentecost he was talking about folks
believe the gospel you and your family
the promises for you you who crucified
Christ you Jews you can be forgiven this
Jesus you crucified he's your Messiah
you can have your sins blotted out in
18800 and some odd years into the future
when Christ begins at this process in a
temple in a building in heaven um where
your sins will then be blotted out at
that
point yeah did she did she just
contradict herself in that same sentence
go back up for a second she's an idiot
she had no clue what she was talking
about a total ignoramus did she just say
that it is impossible that the sins of
men the work of the investigative
judgment the blonding out of sins is to
be accomplished before the second Advent
since the dead are to be judged it is
impo yeah that she's claiming the time
their their position is and this is the
SDA Bible commentary by the way too they
they site on acts 319 to20 they site
this no she's not contradicting herself
she's claiming that the times of
refreshing is going to come after the
investigative judgment that's what I'm
saying so apparently Peter was telling
the hearers there at Pentecost yeah like
a couple thousand years later that your
sins will be blotted out will yeah so
believe the gospel because your sins
will be blotted out in 2,000 years after
you pass this investigative judgment
that's what we're supposed to because
because Christ's work is finished and
it's finished not yet it's finished in
1800 years or 2,000 years when the
investigative judgment closes Christ
will come and his reward will be with
him and to give to every man as his work
shall be now here we go in the typical
service the high priest having made the
atonement for Israel came forth and
bless the congregation so Christ at the
close of his work as
mediator will appear without sin unto
salvation Hebrews 9:28 totally
butchering of that text I've gone
through that chapter I don't know how
many times on this platform to bless is
waiting people with eternal life as the
priest and removing the sins from the
sanctuary confess them upon the head of
the scapegoat so Christ will place all
these sins upon Satan the originator and
instigator of sin the scapegoat bearing
the sins of Israel was sent away unto a
land uninhabited Leviticus 16:22 so
Satan bearing the guilt of all the sins
which he has caused God's people to
commit will be for a thousand years
confined to the Earth which will then be
desolate without inhabitant and he will
at last suffer the full penalty of sin
in the fires that shall destroy all the
wicked thus the great Plan of Redemption
will reach its accomplishment in the
final eradication of sin and the
Deliverance of all who have been willing
to renounce evil so my point in bringing
this up was to say she was saying that
the ceasing without a mediator she says
it multiple times this is I could show
you another place where she says the
same thing and it's ultimately because
part of of the requirement of
vindicating God is silencing Satan's
accusation well what is Satan's
accusation supposedly that the law is
unfair it's it's mutable it needs
changed it can't be kept Etc and Jesus
came as the great example not just to
humans by the way Mike also to Angels
which is a whole thing I'm gonna be
doing a big thing on some research I've
been doing for about six months now on
Michael the Archangel that is going to
blow the lid off my mind has been blown
on this it's way worse than I thought it
was um thank shout out to one of our
members who sent me on a a rabbit hunt
down that that rabbit hole because hold
these smokes but nevertheless Jesus came
as the great example to show you that
the law can be kept she says elsewhere
in Desire of Ages that the scars that he
bears are are evidence to us that the
law can be kept that it can't be changed
and that he'll forever bear these scars
for us to always know look the law can't
be changed and to always remember that
look what the law required required
Christ dying and all these sorts of
things that she says yeah Chop Chop get
to it you better start keeping that law
I wonder how I want to ask the AVST how
well are you doing on that but the
ceasing of the mediator has to do with
people who have gotten to this condition
where they're vindicating La God's law
and demonstrating to the world that
which is supposed to be the Adventist
it's not just supposed to be a select
handful it's supposed to be that they
have this antidote that can really give
you this you know you can come to Christ
and receive this superpower
and now you can really begin keeping the
law if you really really believe and
then you'll get to this point eventually
through cooperation alongside Jesus
where you'll no longer need his imparted
merits to you because that has then
weaved this robe of righteousness that
you're clothed in it's not your own
merits it's only you working alongside
Jesus who's giving you his merits to
weave together this robe of
righteousness that you can then stand
without an intercessor because Jesus
Satan's accusations would would be able
to stand against you if you didn't if
you had any sin left in your life so
once he ceased being a mediator which
they understand to be a process of him
only dealing with sin basically well
he's not going to be dealing with that
anymore so he'll cease doing that and
he'll be advocating for the people that
made it through the investigative
judgment which were the people who kept
the law perfectly so Satan's accusation
won't be able to stand against them
because he'll be able to see well no
look I'm not excusing their sin but it
was dealt with they were penitent and
they eventually get to a point where
they're vindicating the law so Satan's
accusation will be silenced he won't be
able to um even though he's going to try
to accuse them down on the earth um they
it won't be it won't happen that's also
part of why in the system she claimed in
great controversy that during the time
of trouble you're going to have to get
to a point like Jesus was she says this
is the condition you must be in and she
uses the example of Jesus being tempted
in the wilderness the Wilderness is
supposed to be a picture of the time of
trouble and that when Satan was tempting
Jesus out in the wilderness he couldn't
find find any foothold in Christ to make
him to make him fall and she says this
is the condition you must be found in
during the time of trouble because if
not Satan's gonna find something in you
that's going to be able to trip you up
and that's what she's referring to is
this heavenly courtroom scene when the
time of trouble's going on he's gonna be
accusing and if there's any sin found in
you you're not going to make it Jesus is
only going to be able to advocate for
people who got to a totally sinless
condition and that's the plain reading
of the word of God clearly yeah just
just obviously you know Micah is talking
about this I don't know how you could
read the Bible any different by the way
I'm being sarcastic for my friends that
are watching I don't respect trying
theology I was trying to keep up with
all of the the Bible texts that she was
quoting and I was I this this is the
problem with like Adventist theology
because it TR is like Hopscotch jumping
around it really is and it's funny that
someone like Ted Wilson would say the
only approved method is the hgm the
that's the only approved but yet your
own propheus doesn't even use that
method in fact she doesn't even
understand it no not even close and see
they'll use the excuse there like which
I get it they'll say well she's not
citing there as like commentary she's
like just showing biblical well it's
like okay if she's not using it as
commentary I understand that I
understand that you have the LG white
SDA Bible commentary which some of those
were though where she's citing from acts
31 19-20 that's what the SDA Bible
commentary on that verse because I've
shown it on this platform numerous times
that is what she's claiming that text is
saying so in that instance she was
citing it as commentary I understand in
other places she'll periodically just
cite Bible texts because it's it's like
the language that's used she's just
trying to use biblical language I get
that but all it does is just shows how
all over the board this is citing the
Bible like that treating it like this
Divine fortune cookie where it's just
like you just pull stuff out just from
all over the place and oh man it just
makes it look so biblical oh man just
it's just dripping in biblical text yeah
it's just dripping in in just Butchery
of the Bible none of the texts that she
cited have anything to do with what's
being said
here none none of it I mean I even went
to the first one Micah 48 I'm like what
in the world does that even have to do
with what she was trying to say yeah it
doesn't so the deepest interest
manifested among men in the decisions of
Earthly tribunals but faintly represents
the interest evinced in the Heavenly
courts when the names entered in the
Book of Life come up in review before
the judge of all the Earth the Divine
intercessor presents The Plea that all
who have overcome through faith and the
blood uh be forgiven and their transg uh
the Divine intercessor presents The Plea
that all who have overcome through faith
in his blood be forgiven their
transgression
that they be restored to their Eden home
and crowned as joint HS with himself to
quote the first Dominion Micah 48 that's
a let me read let me read Micah 48 let
me let me read it okay and you oh Tower
of the flock Hill of the daughter of
Zion to you shall it come and here you
go the former Dominion shall come
kingship for the daughter of Jerusalem
What in the world does that have
anything to do with what she is trying
to say it doesn't she because it has the
word yeah exactly exactly exactly which
is exactly what will this this is
William Miller exes I shouldn't call it
ex this is William Miller heresy
interpretation yeah where you Bible
interpretation I know it's just crazy
that's what I'm saying it's just like
word concept fallacy it just and that's
and like I've heard Jud Lake and whatnot
when I was a student of his I would talk
with him about this just crazy the
excuses they'll come up with man I just
remembered so I asked him for example
I'm like dude come on be honest she says
that drinking tea is a sin she says that
outright she says drinking tea is a sin
there's tea on this campus they sell tea
in the Village Market they sell tea in
the vending machines on campus how is
that not a contradiction you want to
know what the excuse
was what because you can't go with the
out of context that excuse isn't going
to work on this one because it's just so
patently obvious what being said she
said it was a different kind of tea
that's the excuse that's the excuse tea
back you have to understand teab back
that it's just so pathetic so you're
telling me relish and mustard and black
pepper back there the on the campus was
was was blessed in the blood of Jesus
that's what it was it's just so pathetic
man it's like it's hard to take
seriously because it's just so obvious
it's so obvious just give it up just
give it up well anyways brother like I
said I didn't I didn't anticipate
tonight on tonight's subject that we
would get very few bites um which that's
fine I think we had some good
conversation here I just do want to
remind people just one last thing here
because like I said this is going up
this
week hit that notification Bell so you
can be notified when this goes live this
was a uh a phenomenal interview and it's
not like the rest of interviews that I
do on this platform these are more
documentary like um they're a lot of
work they take a lot of time to to do
and put together and get together and do
the recording and editing and all of
that sort of stuff so definitely
definitely definitely tune in for this
because Mike has an incredible story and
it just so happened to fall that this is
going to go up the same time that you
were here brother thank you so much for
being
here it's an honor um I'm I'm grateful
to be able to participate I'm grateful
that others will hear my testimony uh
and by the way I'll just say this has
nothing to do with me or my wife or my
family this is all all about him um yep
I I owe everything to him so I hope that
my testimony honors him and I hope that
you're blessed by it yeah and you
haven't even seen the uh end product so
it's been a minute since been a minute
since we conducted uh so Mike probably
doesn't even remember much of uh the
specifics of it but I do so definitely
tune in folks and uh May Christ richly
bless you in the grace and peace won by
him and his vicarious death on the cross
for Sinners until next time God bless
sh
[Music]